jean-marie les gars si vous étiez un
perroquet quelle est la phrase que vous
répétez auriez tout le temps à part 18
juin sept de france du ray dieu est
amour
ouais et si vous étiez un caméléon sur
quelle couleur vous poseriez bah je sais
pas je suis ça c'est con comme question
aussi c'est la wii s'il s'agit d'un
caméléon je reprendrais bien soin de ne
pas prendre la couleur du truc sur
lequel je suis je suis assis comme si
j'ai envie qu'on me voit pas du tout me
fondre dans l'espace je veux qu'on ne
voit que moi je suis sur du verre je me
mettrai en rouge ou en bleu si vous
étiez une vache qui aimeriez-vous
brouter jean-marie j'ai bossé isabelle
adjani mais si je viens en vhc pas si si
elle va vouloir
sinon c'était ça qui m'était venu en
premier non si vous étiez un requin
quelle émission aimeriez vous animez
ben je sais pas une émission
sur les requins oui tiens par exemple je
ferais prendre tous les requins auraient
tous les requins de la télé et je ferai
d'animateurs sera une émission avec tous
les animateurs requins de la télé mais
si vous étiez une moule devant quelle
émission aimeriez vous glandez toute la
journée
si j'étais une moule une vieille moules
ou le à l'envié on est à deux doigts du
prénom maintenant vazeille moule
je voudrais dans la mire de faire 3 et
j'étais une jeune moule une jeune moule
toi bien
je vends xxl où il détient phoque avec
qui aimeriez vous coucher et voilà ça y
est on y est parent ils seraient pas
d'accord tony gomez
aa c'est notre copain tony gomez de
l'étoile toi bon copain et je me
laisserais peut-être pénétré par l'idée
un jour et je préfèrerais que ça soit
quitter ce recul est autant que ce soit
par un pote
si vous étiez une oie qu'est-ce qui vous
gavray très rapidement jean marie
geveaux plus d'un rapidement en ce
moment ce qui me gave ce qui va ce qui
ne gâche rien c'est tarak ben ammar la
passion du christ si je peux je dirais
deux trois trucs
si vous étiez une mouche à merde sur qui
aimeriez vous vous posez jean-marie sur
une merde dur ce que j'ai pensé déjà
souvent à la mouche une belle merde dur
un gars qui mangent que du riz grâce
ayez tu te poses tu te poses tu manges
tu manges friture part pas sur une mer
de mol tu t'enfonces jusque là après tu
repartons mais partout ailleurs les bars
ta femme
si vous êtes une vipère vous diriez quoi
de baffie maintenant six mois j'étais
une vipère une vipère je dirais salut ça
va
qu'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est
un jour de ma carte si vous étiez encore
feriez quoi là maintenant je dis pas
c'est un piège si j'étais un port je
dirais venez vous partagez mon corps
parce que tout est bon dans le cochon
je dirais même pour ceux qui veulent
agir et penser qu'ils veulent pas manger
tout de suite s'ils peuvent sucer un peu
avant
et après seulement il mange si vous
étiez à chaque aile schalk vous
préféreriez zuma quelque 6,6 oui c'est
dormons spectacle d'ailleurs eu un truc
bien préparé la crête iroquois et au le
maillot bien fait ce que les celles ci
fille qui dépasse du cabba plus personne
n'en veut les grosses touffes de chaque
côté c'est terminé belle petite chatte
bien préparé pour combien de personnes
sans champignon without me choque
ouais ouais la refaire parce que
maintenant que je connais les questions
ça peut être sympa de la refaire on peut
la refaire et à dosso sinon si jean
marie bigard interview 30 millions
d'amis a dit jean marie bigard si vous
étiez un perroquet quelle est la phrase
que vous répète seriez tout le temps je
vais tenir le 18 juin au stade de france
et dieu est amour d'accord si vous étiez
que sur quelques couleurs aimeriez vous
vous posez j'ai attaqué dès aujourd'hui
rouge serait vert sur le bleu schrey
jaune donc on me voir ce que j'aime bien
comme on voit jean marie bigard c'est
une vache qui aimeriez-vous brouter
isabelle adjani trèfle si vous étiez un
requin quelle émission aimeriez une
émission de requins qui parlerait que
des requins est urgent animaux avec tous
les requins de la télé je fais une
grosse émission et quelques airs cas
jean marie belliard
j'en ai gardé et il moule demandé
journée je glande rsg d une vieille
moule devant la mire de faire 3 mais
c'était une shon moule xxl tous les
films de cul et où jean-marie gars il
détient phoque avec qui aimeriez vous
couchez tony gomez c'est un ami le lot
est à moi il n'est jamais un culé mais
si on le fait ça avec lui jean marie
bigard si les turinois qu'est-ce qui
vous garde devrait rapidement qu'on
parle de la passion du christ tarak ben
ammar on va en parler j'en voyais des
gars si vous étiez une mouche sur quelle
mère diriez-vous fonctionnaires de dures
quelqu'un qui mange du riz
jean-marie voir une belle merde bien dur
parce que la mère de mal tu t'enfonces
dedans et après tu ramènes tous à la
maison du tango des parts à femme
dormait sur les rideaux bardot jean
marie bigard ce meeting vipère qu'est ce
que vous diriez de laurent baffie
et si on parlait un peu de ta calvitie
jean-marie du gard si vous étiez un port
vous feriez quoi là maintenant je dirais
prenez et mangez dans tous puisque tout
et tout est bon dans le cochon
et je dirais si avant de me manger vous
pouvez me sucer un peu ça serait sympa
jean marie bigard si vous étiez un chat
quel genre de chatte vous préféreriez je
préférerais une chatte bien préparés
voilà un truc bien préparés pas avec les
salsifis qui dépasse du cabba oui avec
un truc bien bien taillé et la crète la
cre et iroquois et tout un truc propre
bien taillés à la main sans champignon
si possible on leur fait mais là on leur
fait pour le coup très très très dit
jean-marie iba buts deux mots et toi
speed un peu d'argent il faut rallumer
demain jean marie vidal interview 30
minutes jean pierre kalfon dieu est
amour
jean rivet a cédé 1 gameiro souk el
khoury et marilou et bleu sur le rouge
rouge sur nous mêmes et leurs six
musiciens basques est ce que vous
aimeriez vous savez là johnny jean rigal
sa détient avec un académicien auriez
vous animait une émission de requins et
que le requin elle regarde il est une
boule de manquer l'émission de l'an
dernier au bout duquel ils voulaient
rien une jeune moules les trucs des culs
sens mais obligatoire il me coucher tony
gomez
une loi qui bouclait rapidement tarak
ben ammar jean rigal si vous étiez le
mouiller sur quelle merde et rivaux vous
posez une mère du tueur une belle mère
du divin belga c'est une vipère que je
vous défie la mata si on parlait un peu
ta calvi
et
j'aime à tous parce que tout est bon
dans le cochon dans les médias qui
détient à chaque étape
que feriez-vous which had bien taillé un
truc iroquois nicolas jeanjean d'union
thermale
m